- Wooo! Knicks take Playoff Mountain!
- We’re going from the base camp to our face on a stamp, jueard!
- Bing bong! Yeah! We still do that!
- Hello! It’s your cool dad, Adam Silver.
Welcome to the Eastern Face of Playoff Mountain!
Each team will traverse their own path,
finding opponents on their way to the summit,
where the champion will take on the best of the Western Face.
Please, make your way to your assigned path.
- Hell yeah! I'm hype! Let's go!
-Ahhh!
-Chill, bro. The strongest heroes of the East Lands are all here.
[laughing]
[beep]
- On your mark...
get set...
[beep]
Ball!
[starting tone]
- Slow down!
If we get lost I'm gonna get blamed and sent away!
Relax, I was brought here to guide you.
I think we need to go–
- I'm doing things my way! Rahhhh!
- [sigh]
- M-m-m-maybe, maybe we should turn around.
- Paul George writes that everywhere.
Let's find our first opponent.
- Come out and fight!
Looks like we got a bye.
- Uh...
Uh, guys?
- Huh?
- Looks like the only thing stopping us from playoff success...
is ourselves!
- [RJ:] Ahh!
♪♪♪ Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Riaru-sa misetayo ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Born to be a legend ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Hikari o mezashite ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
[shrill laughter]
- All right, here’s what we do.
I take out all three of them! Rah!!
- Julius! Slow down the pace!
- Necessary spin move!
- Unnecessary spin move!
- The Shadow Knicks have all our moves,
including our flaws.
Which means
Shadow RJ shouldn’t be able to shoot from there!
- Hey! Not true!
[power blast]
[power charging]
- W-w-whoa!
- Careful!
Spikes!
- I’ve put up with a lot,
but this is the Knicks team that finally breaks me!
- Every year it’s something.
- I knew we shouldn't have given up on Reddish!
- Maybe New York is a Nets town?
- Too...far.
- [evil laughter]
- [grunt]
- You’re...under...sized!
- I’m the same height as Donovan Mitchell!
-[Evil laughter] You can’t defeat us!
We’re the Knicks!
We’re already defeated!
- And we by far...
- have more demons...
- than anyone else here!
Playoff pressure!
- Too...much...pressure...
I’m out.
- [Evil laughter] Collapsing in crunch time?
The Knicks are so predictable.
- Predictable? These Knicks?
Haha! Now Julius!
- Jump...
pass!
- Haha!
- [groaning]
He left his feet! That should never work!
You can’t escape me forever!
I have facial recognition software!
[blast]
- Looks like your plan worked.
- All we needed was some heart.
- Sorry I’m late.
- En garde!
Ah! It's just the Knicks.
This should be an easy fight.
- Trust us, it’s harder than you think.
- Who will reach the top of Playoff Mountain
and lay claim to the new face of the league?
- Hell if I know.
I just know they get paid a hell of a lot more than when I was a hero.
Also my playoff prediction:
Wizards and the great Bradley Beal win it all.
- Shut up, Chuck!
I’m trying to wrap up the season!
- Uh oh! Rebound!
- Ahh! Not the face! My endorsements!